[Music]
after after I lost the Emmy my people we
all got together and they said Tim you
got to get back out there you know you
gotta you got to turn this around well
you've got a lot of people said you're
gonna win the Emmy this year you didn't
get a nomination this year I was I was
nuking I don't remember you be in there
no I wasn't I wasn't I almost went
anyway right but I wasn't nominated were
you nominated well this settled down
then huh okay it hurts
by the way you're not lack of the
nomination that was pre food face lawyer
so Oscar for that yeah look it's tough
these Emmy nominations I don't know if
you read like I do you know the blogs
and the the analysts the experts I don't
read a lot of that stuff I read them
obsessively not on everything just the
big stuff you know the Emmys the Oscars
The Voice you know the things that and I
think the feeling for the business I
think you're gonna find this interesting
pre nomination the feeling was amongst
the experts that all of it would
probably not be nominated but if he was
most likely would win
and so that didn't work out right and so
yeah that that didn't work what do you
think was the problem do you think there
was maybe something did you throw a
curveball question you ask these things
yes because sometimes it's clear
sometimes wheel kelsey grammer he's in a
he's a Republican he's not gonna get the
nomination right that was clear it was a
little thing I read somewhere I thought
it was interesting but me I wasn't a lot
of people thought it was the accent the
accent now as I said I'm a big fan of
your show takes place in Kentucky my
characters from Kentucky yeah I don't
know if you picked up on this the third
season I went for a little less Kentucky
a little more Virginia just to mix it up
just to mix it up you changed your
character's accent I figure I am you
know television you want to keep it
fresh you know for me for the people I
thought audiences and critics would love
it you know a little magic a little
unexplainable magic right but doesn't
that make people it might have hurt it
might have hurt clearly it's strange
when a character is supposed to be from
Kentucky and suddenly they're talking
from gym it you know there were Jamaica
next year now Jamaica could have got it
done yeah for season four you're gonna
be from gymnasium for only in the
writers room tomorrow with that idea
okay are you gonna what else are you
planning are you planning on doing
something a little more drastic you you
got to go for it you know I feel and
obviously the subtle stuff I've been
working on it's not enough not doing it
I mean people do love the show yeah
if your compliment enough I just needed
a little well also people do
I can't flap on cue
[Applause]
[Music]
I just know I know you boys are gonna
break this toy please be careful so so
what are you working on you're gonna try
something really bold I just came from
the writers room we're always looking
for something and I was thinking and
this is not yet happening so we'll just
feel it out amongst you and your people
will test it right here I was thinking
and you way into all right I will
you're right here I am literally what if
my character Raylan in US Marshal this
year opening episode gun shootout not
shot and killed because that's not but
just the bullet grazes his upper lip and
then there's a lisp that begins you want
Raylan who look for my money is one of
the coolest guys on television US
Marshal from Kentucky / Jamaica you want
him to suddenly start talking in a lisp
it's just an idea can you give us what
kind of list would you go for well you
know you it's got to be something that's
like
[Applause]